good morning  i have good news for european citizens  today  the european union has kept its word  this weekend  we have delivered enough vaccines to  member states  to be in a position to vaccinate fully  at least  70 percent of the eu adults still this  month  and by tomorrow some 500 million doses  of vaccines  will have been distributed so the  european union delivers  our vaccination campaign has accelerated  tremendously since the beginning of the  year  our joint approach is a success  because we will only come out of this  crisis together  but covet 19 is not yet defeated  we are prepared to deliver more vaccines  including  against new variants now member states  must do everything possible to increase  vaccinations  only then will we be safe  g